because there's so many like cool things
in jojo like okay
the jojo like fashion is like the
coolest dude it is [ __ ] nice it's
like by far
i think the best anime fashion like yeah
i don't think anything comes closer i
mean you know that's how they did a
collab with like
the gucci collection you know if they do
another joke was it gucci louis vuitton
as well i'm pretty sure
a short i think it's a 12 page or three
page yeah
yeah yeah and it's [ __ ] amazing and i
wish that i had like no
anime comes close to like pure like
fashion style
i mean it really doesn't iraqi did a
[ __ ] uh jojo exhibition at the louvre
yeah yeah i mean it's like no other
animation
right it's not even close and the reason
why is because anime is such a
i feel like it's been like watered down
style right almost like your style is so
same at this point and then you have
something like jojo that yes
is very very grating to look at in the
start
but the more you come into it the more
you get into it you're like holy [ __ ]
okay
this is really [ __ ] cool no because i
feel like after about i think it's part
four or part five where araki
gets gay
so much gay tension in part five it's
like perfect
i've never seen that many open chests
and you can see how much of like uh
fashion is rubbed how much fashion is
like rubbed off
onto his like character designs and just
like the entire aesthetic like
well most of the poses from like part
four or five onwards are all like
just vogue yeah just covers or like
fashion shots yeah taken
yeah and they're just like amazing in
anime form like yeah it's so obvious
that he had like
an appreciation for fashion that i don't
think many authors had i'm sure some of
the comments who's like um
actually but you know super mainstream
they just
haven't seen that yeah it's it's it's
someone who love obviously loves fashion
but has been able to integrate it in so
well such a
no way because you know there's there's
a difference between having
like i don't i don't know how to put
this into words but like having
characters wear
good fashion like one of the things i
love about rental girlfriend actually
is how like their outfits change right
now
i was one of the few like like anime you
see where every
every episode the character is wearing
like a different outfit right can tell
you can tell like like the authors put
thoughts into this but like
what i feel about jojo fashion is it's
just that it
embodies fashion you know what i mean
not just the clothes but just like the
whole
the whole it feels like
runway models yeah with personality yeah
like dare i say oh my god that is like
so
jojo's yeah like from part five onwards
it does feel like everyone is
runway models with superpowers like
that's
genuinely like what it feels like and it
and like i never gave a [ __ ] about
fashion but ever since like what getting
into jojo like when i saw like
high fashion stuff like expensive [ __ ]
like yeah kind of like looks pretty
[ __ ]
like it's true though i literally never
i always used to think like ten dollars
for a t-shirt is the max level yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah and then the more i got like i
started looking at jersey and i'm like
why is that guy hot like he looks
[ __ ] dumb
but like it's hot though like like yeah
and then i was like dude his outfit is
[ __ ]
cool yeah that's all the clean yeah that
drip clean man
and you're like okay maybe i can start
to appreciate fashion a little bit oh
yeah
i definitely got came to the same
because i mean uh you know this is brand
in
japan called glam which does a massive
oh which you want if you're wondering
where we get most of our
like anime t-shirts now it's probably
from cloud yeah all of the jojo shirts
that you've seen
is probably probably from glow yeah like
i scoffed the first time i saw when the
t-shirt was like eighty dollars yeah
yeah
that is a lot and i pained me to pay
that but after a while i'm like
this [ __ ] looks so good yeah i would
rather have one of this t-shirt than
eight shitty teachers yeah yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying like there's
only a few places where i can rep
like my favorite anime and not have to
worry about being [ __ ] embarrassed
being that cringy weave right yeah
because like there's some anime fashion
which there's no other way i can put it
but just it's just tacky
that's so attached
yeah it's just like the the kind of
shirts you only wear to anime
conventions
and that's it yeah or or as pajamas
exactly but something like the jojo
fashion i've seen just looked [ __ ]
fantastic yeah exactly and you can like
you can be a weeb just like in public
you know and still
yeah that diavolo jacket i have a king
crimson jacket yeah that's so [ __ ]
sick
i love one jacket it's so [ __ ] damn